ja ich war am 21 der kunsthof urlaub in
scheps bin derzeit in aller früh
aufgestanden weil ich weiterfahren
wollte und sehe auf der straße sehr
viele beamte mit karabiner mit tornister
mich gefragt was ist los
man sagte die russin der
tschechoslowakei marschiert ja
fürchterlich es hat damals noch kein
handy gegeben und sie trifft von
verbindungen wenn auch nicht so wie
heute
ich bin daher unverzüglich zum bezirk
schon da marica kommando gegangen habe
mich dort ausgewiesen und da versuchte
man dienstgespräch nach wann ich bin
dann unverzüglich nach mainz gefahren
haben wir wenn dein dienst gestellt und
dort war die alarmierung längst vorbei
es ist alles blitzschnell und hat
bestens funktioniert und alles war
bereits bereit lediglich die muss schon
war nicht da das hat das elf stunden
gedauert bis die munition von den lagern
geholt worden war
ich habe danach einen auftrag bekommen
es hat das meldungen gegeben dass
schwere russische kampfpanzer sich der
österreichischen staatsgrenze nicht
ernähren
ich musste daher mit einem privatauto
einem unverwüstlichen vw käfer in zivil
an die staatsgrenzen zwar nach nürnberg
fahren und mann mit bart und zur wache
erkundigen was ist da los
er passt das warschauer pakt
die bilder der warschauer pakt beim zwar
mit gehabt haben wie vor der zur wache
dort ausgewiesen unter anderen uns meinl
auftrag gesagt sie haben sicherlich
keine ahnung gehabt davon
die leute die das ange weg sagt dann
waren längst weg gefahren also der
auftrag war für nichts und wieder nichts
und es hat sich gezeigt dass das fehlen
von tut man der grenze ja wirklich ein
schwerer schwerer fehler war auch in
diesem fall centers gezeigt